so to review how we got at least to this
video
in 1865 mendel first shares his laws of
inheritance he he observes that there
are these heritable factors these these
discrete heritable factors that would be
passed down from parent to offspring
according to certain rules and he came
up with the laws of inheritance law of
segregation law of independence
assortment law of dominance but as we've
said multiple times that work at the
time that it was first shared wasn't
taken that seriously in fact a lot of
people didn't pay attention to it and it
wasn't until the early 1900s that it was
rediscovered but even when it was first
rediscovered around 1900
people did not know what the molecular
basis for these heritable factors that
mendel talked about what what the basis
of these factors were and in 1902 we
have the first really solid theory for
what the molecular basis for those
inheritable factors actually could be
this is when bovary and sutton come up
and they independently did their work
but they both came to the same theory at
around the same time they came up with
the chromosome theory now called the
bovary sutton chromosome theory and
their work was based on observing
observing how cells divide especially
meiosis and then seeing how these
chromosomes seem to pair up then
segregate then
independently assort and get passed on
to their offspring and they said hey
these chromosomes on a physical level on
a molecular level seem to be behaving in
a ways that are very similar to the
heritable factors that mendel talked
about so it was a very strong theory and
then we get to 1911 where that theory
gets some more evidence put behind it
thomas hunt morgan we talked about it he
used his fruit flies to to see how that
mutant trait that
would pass on from one generation to
another and the only plausible
explanation that he could come up with
is that it would be it was being passed
on on the x sex chromosome and him and
his team continue to do more and more
work to establish that chromosomes
indeed seem to be the basis the physical
location for these heritable factors
that mendel first talked about in 1865
but even morgan and his team when they
looked at chromosomes you know a lot of
times now when we think of chromosomes
we think of chromosomes as being made up
of dna and that is true but chromosomes
are also made up of other things
including proteins and in the early days
when people said hey it looks like
chromosomes are really the basis or the
location for these heritable factors for
these genes when people looked at these
two different molecules they said hey
it's probably it's probably the proteins
that are actually responsible for
encoding the information of inheritance
proteins where these
what people knew were these complex
molecules that in some ways you could
say encoded information while at the
time they thought dna was were these
kind of boring molecules that surely
this couldn't this couldn't encode
information and so the first evidence
strong evidence that dna is actually
where the where the the genetic
information is encoded doesn't happen
for several more decades
and we start along that path with
griffith right over here famous for
griffith's experiment where he does
something really interesting and he by
himself his experiments in 1920 or that
he publishes in 1928 or he actually
conducts and publishes in 1928 they
aren't responsible in and of themselves
for establishing dna to be the the
molecule that's actually the basis of
inheritance but they start an
interesting path of inquiry where these
gentlemen in 1944 are finally able to
establish that dna is where the the in
these inherit these heritable factors
are actually encoded so what was
griffith's experiment
well he was he was studying the strain
of strains of bacteria and he saw that
the same the two variants on a certain
strain of uh or two variants of bacteria
you had the rough strain and the smooth
stain strain if he injected the rough
strain into a mouse the mouse lived if
he injected the smooth strain into a
mouse the mouse died
and it was because the smooth strain had
this protective coating on it that made
it harder to attack by the mouse's
immune system so that by itself well
that's that's interesting this is this
is the virulent strain this is the one
that's actually going to kill the mice
now if he took this smooth strain the
virulent strain and he heated up so they
were they were those bacteria were
killed and then he injected those so
this is the heat killed smooth strain if
he injected those into the mouse the
mouse still lived because those bacteria
were dead but then he did something very
very very interesting
he took this the heat killed smooth
strain he took some of that and he took
some of the live rough strain put
together now common sense would tell you
is like okay this blue stuff that's not
going to kill the mouse and this this
killed this killed smooth strain that's
not going to kill the mouse either so if
i mix it up that shouldn't kill the
mouse but it did kill the mouse which
was fascinating and so he came up with
this theory of a transformation
principle even though he killed the
smooth strain here there must have been
some type of material some some type of
molecule that still got transferred from
the dead bacteria to the live bacteria
and essentially transformed the live
bacteria into
the smooth strain allowing them to kill
the mouse
and so he came up with this idea of some
kind of transformation principle
and so you can imagine and look it took
some time several
over over ten years now almost two
decades avery mccarty and mcle mclead
said hey well what what is this
transformation principle why don't we
use griffith's experiment and let's keep
instead of just taking you know pure the
whole
heat killed smooth strain let's try to
break it up into its components and
let's try to isolate the different
components and keep doing the experiment
until we have an isolated a molecule or
an isolated component that seems to do
the trick so they were trying to isolate
the transformation principle and they
did just as what i described they took
the heat killed smooth strain they would
try to separate the different the
different constituents out there's
different there's you can you can
separate them out physically you should
you could use certain washes that would
wash away certain components you could
use enzymes that would destroy certain
components
and eventually and this is very
meticulous work so you can imagine they
take they take the stuff
you know the whole dead
heat killed smooth strain and they start
to separate it out into its various
components so that might be
that might be
one component right over there
this is another let me do it in these
different colors
this is another component
right over there
this is another component right over
there they're using different chemical
techniques to separate all of the
constituents that were in that original
heat killed smooth strain and then
instead of running this last this last
phase of the experiment with the entire
heat killed smooth strain they do it
with the rough strain mixed with each of
these components separately and then
they kept running the experiment and
they would say hey look when we have
this component right over here and we
tried to run the experiment the mouse
still lives
the mouse still is so this one did not
transform the rough strain and maybe
this one also did not transform the
rough strain but then eventually they
were able to isolate the something that
did transform the rough strain so the
mouse
the mouse dies and so it did transform
the rough strain into the smooth strain
and so they took this material and they
start applying all sorts of tests to it
they could look at the
the molecular components of it and when
they looked at the ratios of nitrogen
and phosphorus they say hey this seems
to have ratios that are consistent with
dna which is a molecule they already
knew about and it was not ratios that
would have been consistent with proteins
they ran chemical tests say hey there
doesn't look like there's a lot of
protein in this thing that we isolated
or even rna which is another molecule
that they knew
enzymes that would have degraded
proteins or rna did not degrade this
stuff but if the enzymes that degraded
dna did degrade this stuff and so they
were able to come up with the idea that
dna was the transformation principle and
this is a really really really big deal
think about this quest that we've been
going through for the better part of a
hundred years inheritable factors well
where are they located hey it looks like
they're on the chromosomes we start
having evidence that they're on the
chromosomes but chromosomes are made up
of dna and proteins and it wasn't until
the start with griffith's experiment and
then avery mccarty and mclead come along
and say hey let's identify what was it
exactly about the heat killed smooth
strain what's the component in it that
actually transformed the other strain
and it was dna and what was fascinating
is when you mixed that dna from the
rough killed
rough
from the heat killed smooth strain with
the rough strain that dna was something
was was able to mix in with the dna of
the rough strain and allows it to start
producing these smooth protein coats
that allowed it to be more violent so
the mouse's immune system couldn't
attack it as well so it's really
fascinating on a lot of levels you know
the whole takeaway from this one is how
did we get to dna being the important
part of the chromosomes at least in
terms of encoding the actual genetic
information but it's also a cool way to
think about
just just on something else how magical
dna is
that if you mix it in if you mix it in
the dna of of one strain with a a live
version of another strain that you
actually might be able to transform that
strain so you're actually you know in
some ways they were doing very uh very
very basic genetic engineering here